[Music]
generally speaking if you're watching
something with a teen character they're
likely being played by an adult actor
there are many reasons for this but some
castings
truly push the boundaries of
believability here are some of the most
notable cases of grown adults playing
high schoolers
beverly hills 90210's cast was a mixed
bag of teens and adults when the show
first premiered in 1990. the characters
were supposed to be sophomores in high
school during the first season so a
range of 15 to 17 would have been
realistic
but most of the cast members were
already in their upper teens when the
show began
tori spelling was 17 when she started
out as donna martin as was brian austin
greene who was actually playing a
freshman as david silver
shannon doherty and jason priestley who
played fraternal twins brenda and
brandon walsh
were 20 and 21 years old while bad boy
dylan was played by the late luke perry
who was a whopping 25
at the time the most shocking casting
however was that of gabrielle carteres
as andrea suckerman
the character is supposed to be super
smart and way more mature than her peers
andrea focuses on getting ahead
academically instead of partying but
carteres was 29 years old when she
signed one to play 16 year old andrea
according to reports carteres lied about
her age and told the casting director
she was
over 21 when she auditioned but in the
show's fifth season
carterest's real-life pregnancy forced
the writers to incorporate the pregnancy
into andrea's storyline which led to the
character's eventual
exit from the show when party of five
premiered in 1994
the main characters consisted of 24 year
old eldest brother charlie
played by matthew fox 16 year old bailey
played by scott wolf
julia 15 played by nev campbell
eleven-year-old claudia played by
actress lacey chabert
and baby owen age one shaver was
obviously in the same age range as her
character
as was baby owen but campbell was 21
when the series began
and fox was 28. scott wolfe was 26 when
he landed the role of bayley a full
10 years older than his character bayley
was a rebellious teen who took on more
responsibility
after the salinger parents were killed
in a car accident
later in the storyline wolf's character
deals with alcoholism and pulls away
from his family
bailey's arc is defined by his
relationship with his on-again off-again
girlfriend
sarah played by jennifer love hewitt in
the end perhaps wolfe's maturity helped
him capture the essence of his bayley
counterpart
dawson's creek had quite a few teenagers
among its original cast when it first
aired in 1998
many of the characters were high school
sophomores and a majority of those
starring roles went to actors of a
pretty close age range
michelle williams was 17 when she played
the 16 year old
jen lindley fifteen-year-old dawson was
played by twenty-year-old james van der
beek
and fifteen-year-old pacey and
sixteen-year-old joey were played by a
nineteen-year-old joshua jackson
and eighteen-year-old katie holmes but
then the mcphee siblings arrived and
threw off dawson's age-appropriate
groove
i have always been this complete butts
some things never change no
everything changes in season two jack
and andy mcphee joined the gang
and all those teenage hormones were
interrupted by 20-something shenanigans
actor kerr smith was 26 when he stepped
onto the set of dawson's creek as jack
the record however goes to meredith
monroe who was 28 years old when she
started playing andy
both siblings are supposed to be just
16.
on fox's musical high school comedy glee
it might as well have been a requirement
to be an adult playing a teenager most
actors were significantly
older than the teenage characters they
were playing leah michelle was 23 when
she took on 15 year old rachel berry as
for mercedes actor amber riley
and quinn actor diana egron heather
morris and nya rivera were both 22 when
the show began
the only one whose age still ended as a
teen was 19 year old chris golfer whose
character kurt is supposed to be
16 but the biggest age gap goes to the
late corey monteith who was 27 years old
when he was cast
as the 15 year old finn hudson sure
monteith seemed young but not as young
as an actual 15 year old with the
incredible shooting and rehearsal
demands of a show like glee
it's not surprising the producers went
with actors who were all over 18
so that they didn't have to deal with
any minor centric acting laws
monty's age afforded him a unique wealth
of life experience especially when
compared to some of his castmates
before he broke into hollywood monteith
had worked as a walmart greeter
roofer cab driver and school bus driver
as is the case with so many shows all
the kids on gilmore girls were played by
adults
when the show started out rory played by
alexis bledel and her pals are
sophomores in high school
bledell was 19 while playing her 16 year
old character
by far the show's most reasonable age
match her main love interests are 16
year old dean played by an 18 year old
jared patalecki
and 15 year old jess played by a then 23
year old milo ventimiglia rory's 16 year
old nemesis paris was played by 23 year
old liza wilde
you might think those 23 year old actors
are pushing it but the president of the
two old for school club one gilmore
girls has to be rory's bff lane kim who
was played by keiko aguenna
if you could live in any city in the
world you'd pick philadelphia m night
shyamalan live there
who the guy who directed the sixth sense
at the time magenta was 27 with laura ly
gilmore being 32
played by 33 year old lauren graham the
actor playing lane was closer in age to
her best friend's mom than she was to
her best friend
we can't say a genna didn't pull it off
her lane is full of youthful exuberance
but there's something undeniably funny
about graham and aguenna being real
world peers playing a mom
and a young girl on tv buffy the vampire
slayer began in 1997 with main
characters who are supposed to be
sophomores in high school
buffy played by sarah michelle geller
was 19 playing a 16 year old
willow her witchy best friend forever is
also 16 and was played by 19 year old
alison hannigan
nicholas brendan was much older at 26
than his sophomore character
xander the oldest member of the cast was
david boreanaz who at 35 was playing
vampire with a soul angel
who was supposed to be about 20 or like
250
depending on how you look at it but the
oldest actor playing an actual teenager
was charisma carpenter who at 27 took on
the role of cordelia chase
yet another sophomore when cordelia
leaves the scooby gang in season 3 for
the cast of angel they bumped her up in
age a bit
so that it didn't feel so awkward we'll
give you one guess as to how old the
characters in riverdale are supposed to
be
if you guess sophomores in high school
you win the cast of riverdale features a
whole gang of actors in their early 20s
playing characters who are supposed to
be 15 or 16 years old
the only actual teen is kj appa who was
19 when the show started out the other
actors lily reinhardt
ross butler camila mendes ashanti
bromfield
madeline petch cole sprouse and casey
cott
all range in age from 20 to 26 but the
eldest member of the riverdale gang is
ashley murray
who was 30 when she started playing teen
rocker josie
of josie and the pussycats they were
from your father's gang weren't they
this means that murray is old enough to
have been the target audience for the
2001
josie and the pussycats movie how's that
for perspective
zombie apocalypse drama the walking dead
isn't a teen show
though a lot of teens count themselves
as fans it is a show full of grown
adults fighting for their lives
occasionally however kids and teens
become entangled in the violent bloody
fight for survival
one character of note is carl lead
character rick rime's son who grows from
being a kid to a teen throughout the
series but aside from carl's actor
chandler riggs there aren't many teen
actors on the show
much like other shows in which adults
are cast as teens the walking dead
probably
did so because of the series super
demanding shooting schedule the most
popular teen on the walking dead has
likely been
beth green fan favorite herschel's
youngest daughter
beth appears in seasons 2 through 5 and
is supposed to be about 16 years old
in reality beth was played by emily
kinney who was 26 years old when she was
on the series
beth's death is a sad one since the
character is so sweet and kind
but hey them's the brakes on the walking
dead
smallville tells the story of superman's
high school days in the kansas town he
grew up in
though the young clark is supposed to be
14 years old when the show begins
the lead actor tom welling was 24 years
old at the time but really
does age matter when aliens and
superheroes are at play
superman returns starring brandon routh
debuted in 2006
smack in the middle of smallville's run
returns centers around a grown-up
superman
well into his cape-wearing ears dealing
with mature issues of romance and his
career
yet ralph was three years younger than
welling then playing clark kent as a
high schooler by the time the show
wrapped up
welling was 34 years old throw in a 29
year old michael rosenbaum playing a 21
year old lex luthor
and you've got one geriatric cast
of the four main characters on the oc
only one started out the show as an
actual teenager
misha barton was 17 years old when the
series began
only a blip older than her character
marissa who is you guessed it
a sophomore in high school other leads
like seth and summer were played by
23 year old adam brody and 21 year old
rachel bilson
the oldest member of the oc cast was ben
mckenzie who was 24 when he started
playing ryan atwood
bad boy ryan is supposed to be the new
guy in town who shows the rich kids of
the oc how to misbehave and have a good
time
at least mckenzie's age gave his bad boy
vibe a little more believability
veronica mars premiered in 2004 with
kristen bell playing high school private
detective veronica in a major departure
from teen show tradition
veronica mars is actually a junior when
the show begins
the second season follows her senior
year while the third chronicle is
veronica's freshman year at the
fabulously named
neptune's hearst college belle was
already well into her 20s when the show
began
in 2004 she was 24 years old making her
about seven years
older than the character by the time the
series wrapped she was 27.
i'm heading out of town and
not sure when i'll be back the veronica
mars film that debuted in 2014
sees the neptune high gang attend their
10-year high school reunion even though
their graduation was in 2006
the fourth season which hit hulu in 2019
is set in that year with veronica
presumably around age 32
again played by belle at the age of 39.
all things considered veronica mars
should be proud of itself
few teen shows could have handled such a
disjointed decade spanning existence
with as much smoothness as it did
fonzie isn't a high schooler on happy
days but he does start out as a teenager
the 1970 series created by the late gary
marshall
is set in the 1950s starring ron howard
as richie cunningham
an average high school kid in the
midwest his best friend and the
cunningham's tenant who lives above the
garage
is arthur fonzarelli aka fonzie or
the fonz played by henry winkler fonzie
starts out the show at 19 years old but
winkler was already way into his 20s
when the show
began at 29 the actor was a full decade
older than his character
a high school dropout who is seen as the
bad boy of the very traditional
1950s setting fonzie proves them all
wrong however when he earns his high
school diploma via night school
eventually becoming a teacher by the
time happy days end it
winkler was 39 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one